[Music]
in more inclusive news what's that mean
submitted by amici a group of kids wants
an ice cream company to change the name
of its great divided flavor to make it
more inclusive
what's the great divide flavor it's one
so it's chocolate ice cream on one side
and vanilla balm oh oh wait what's the
problem well I think it's the Great
Divide sounds like segregation and
they're keeping the white and the
chocolate apart but those idiots are
filling in the blanks themselves and
making it racial yeah it's a who's that
kids
kid but what about the people in the
center that seemed very friendly with
each other well you know if you take the
great divide right you just melt it down
it'll just turn it stir it up a little
bit just turn into bows yeah that's
right I mean we call it bows nobody get
to the bottom it says bows at the end so
what do they want they what like soft
snow comes out spinning we're like it's
like the vanilla and the chocolate are
already coming together whoo for some
reason I look very sexual like they're
dancing and [ __ ] there are ice creams
though that they're just swirled like
they're not divided like that I mean
like they're not blended but it's just
swirled and it stops yeah when you bite
into it it's like you don't what about
Neapolitan ice cream they have the pink
they have the white and the brown but
it's not called divided but I mean my
thing but you know I just want a
different name I don't like my food
touching each other you know so like
what if I want to eat a little bit of
vanilla and sometimes you would hate the
way he eats he smashes everything
together like it's [ __ ] dog food it's
get wild yeah like the most delicious
spread of food right and then he'll do
this here though dub dub dub spoon it's
like III chooses food before it goes in
his mouth yeah you ever heard loco moco
no pop the yolks and it drizzles all
over and then the gravy and then the
meat and then you swirl it and then it
changes the texture oh good that's like
people I know that'll like take a pizza
and then put more stuff on it and then
just roll it up and I'm like why are you
doing that look should somebody put
mashed potatoes on a pizza before what
do you get
potatoes and pizza I don't know Shakey's
not to go too far off and talk about
food again I changed my tune yeah I
changed my favorite fast-food pizza
joint where is it now it's now round
table oh I need to go there
that sounds work Danny sound organic the
place people have been sleeping on round
table bro table people you can get a
personal round table you know like that
mini one like this big they make it
fresh why did you apologize and then the
whole [ __ ] segments about pizza or
food wait what did I say you said I
didn't need to go off-topic it's all
about food again but i'ma talk about
food for the next 10 min oh yeah ask
David talk about pizza yes amen
it's gonna be buff ass [ __ ] you boy ty
Davis soon dude all right so this mom
who has six children of her own and she
fosters more so she has a luncheon why
is she fostering so much I don't know
she wants foster a foster [ __ ] foster
farms ass Foster's Australian for beer
her name is Tracy from Louisiana good
for her no that's awesome we need we
need people to foster children so she
posted this photo here with a pretty
long caption it's pretty much like a
letter from three of her kids who are 11
10 and 8 and they're saying that she was
just saying that I can't believe she
mixed all those flavors together
should've kept them separate and she
doesn't have any light-skinned babies I
want to talk to Tracy exactly mm-hmm huh
so as she was saying I'm raising my kids
to be a bunch of [ __ ] and you guys
are infringing on that right all right
so the letter from the kid says hi
Bluebell we love your ice cream we all
think cookies and cream is the best ice
cream on the planet last week we had an
ice-cream party and we had the flavor
the Great Divide it's a good flavor for
parties because we can add a lot of
unique toppings to it but we began to
talk about the name and we think some
people might misunderstand the name and
think the name the Great Divide is about
people and the division that exists in
our world because of different skin
colors great you know what black people
and white people should stay away from
each other
that is ridiculous you know what people
think they go there like man I wanted
vanilla and chocolate but guess what
okay bones yeah so [ __ ] happy except
Tracy and her eight kids yeah relax
so this letters from Isaac Caleb and
Jaden so then they jump in your kids
Isaac and Caleb have lighter skin and
Jaden has darker skin but Isaac and
Caleb also have a brother and sister
adopted from foster care who have dark
skin as well we are all our own color
and own flavor and there is no divide
between us but why they bring you race
into it though it's also did you notice
in that picture the white kids were on
one side of the picture and there was
one that was min sober you know what she
probably said Kwan go over the hip
applause this is the Great Divide Tracy
I'm upset with you when what with one
chocolate straggler yeah so we have a
suggestion for a new name for your
chocolate and vanilla ice cream flavor
better together isn't that Hillary's
thing better together yeah what was it
oh no no I'm with her right I'm gonna
learn yeah and also better better
together doesn't represent why people
like getting the chocolate and vanilla
cause you get to choose which one you
want yeah and this is just kind of
stupid and I think like you're actually
doing a disservice to your kids because
you're making your kids think about
color a little too much yeah
it's two races racially driven like when
I go to a yogurt land or whatever I have
a Great Divide all the time it's always
a great yeah I don't [ __ ] mix it all
together in there exactly but I'm
socially conscious so I put the vanilla
on the bottom and I put all the colors
on top that's what I [ __ ] do that's
right and everybody knows what's it
melts a little bit the white starts
becoming a little brown I've softened up
a lot of men before I'm sorry
girl answer bluebells spokesman said you
dumb [ __ ]
quote we created Great Divide so that
families didn't have to choose between
two favorites but could both enjoy
homemade vanilla and dutch chocolate in
one container it's great I think you
talk about Dutch chocolate
we love that bacon chocolate better
together and especially the thoughtful
sentiment behind it but then when they
ask the company if they are gonna change
it means [ __ ] ah he declined to
comment practically like I mean think
about it how much [ __ ] money that to
put in [ __ ] a new graph that design
everything packaging they have to
reprint so much [ __ ] but that sucks
because like I feel like these parents
are putting their like social justice
awareness into these kids who don't even
really have to think about it they could
just be kids yeah they're gonna they're
gonna argue that it was the kids who
came up with it but you made them think
of raised kids or if you implement these
are you hammer them in there to go the
other way you just raise a bunch of
white no I feel like these kids are
probably so consumed by it I just like
the media and every like literally every
place everything everything's about race
right now yeah all of our race I don't
think it's just the parents probably
like putting it into it it could be
their schools and everything too cuz I
heard that it's all [ __ ] everything
but that's only two and our age too
because you're talking about LA riots we
all grew up that [ __ ] see when I was a
kid here's something here's an example
right so uh I have a friend back at home
his name is John Paul this dude did not
[ __ ] know until recently when I met
what met up with him like a couple years
ago he had a tagalog accent as a kid
I've known that dude all the way through
high school I had no idea how to act
until I got older and because I grew up
with it since elementary school so as a
kid I didn't even know he was like a
foreign like immigrant until I got more
than when where race started becoming a
little bit more apparent to me so as a
kid I didn't [ __ ] know that he was
just my friend John Paul he wasn't the
Filipino kid he was how it should be
exactly so I think like that is
something that I'm not so much against
but that's like stuff that you should
bring up when they're a little bit older
they become a little bit more aware but
having your kids to constantly think
about race and color race and color race
and color race it yeah already creates
yeah and it also prevents people from
devel
being their own individual personality
because once you start thinking about
like identity politics and group and
race they go oh I do this because I'm
black or I do this because I'm Asian or
I'm not Asian enough because I'm not
doing math well or whatever you know so
people really start believing that they
are the group instead of an individual
who has their own likes and dislikes I
read something that it's not something
along the lines of like when kids are
grown up hearing about groups of people
they're less likely to sympathize with
someone that's not part of their own
group yeah yeah just like hurts even
more
I mean it just sounds like it was like
it was ice cream time for this family
and these kids and they were like oh
look this is like you like the slaver
looks like you oh this favorite looks
like me Oh
or whatever you know and then they were
like wait what like I don't know maybe
they were like if they could read I
don't know what age kids start reading
but they're like oh why is it called the
Great Divide there's some shitty kids
you know why if you open that [ __ ] up
mimic Asian family while you're talking
I'm eatin you finish talking the ice
cream is gone [ __ ]
one in this one oh my god actually have
that died so that does happen yeah that
does but I'm saying like he could have
been a moment where the malt like I
don't know where the month like they're
like well why is it called a divide
isn't that or whatever good is what
chocolate and vanilla right but then
instead of the mom being like oh cuz you
know all of you guys are great and you
know you put two great things together
wrote a letter she was like out what is
it called divine I was thinking it was
more like educate them you she said in
the article she was saying my kids and I
were having ice cream at a birthday
party but while I was like that's not
how it happened Tracy the kids were
having a nice time everybody's eating
their ice cream she's sitting there
looking at it she's like so what do you
kids think about racial equality in
America that's exactly how I pictured
exactly like no actually recently I
heard someone say out loud so they were
being served chicken and this white lady
was like she got dark balls
she's bummed out that she got dark meat
but then this Latino dude that was near
a low quality taste but I know
especially he got white meat and so he
ends up telling her like oh hey you know
we can switch like I love dark meat you
know you can have the white meat and
she's like
oh my god yeah because I'm white and
you're dark yeah we're like I love
unintentional racism because it's like
so [ __ ] it's almost cute how stupid
it is like they don't even mean harm but
it's so [ __ ] up
ya know she kept saying a lot of like
who could [ __ ] a lot of those yeah I
love that [ __ ] though and then she
starts to sing an ebony the only time I
like white meat is if it's in a
chick-fil-a burger oh that's so good
mm-hmm know how to make it juicy sorry I
put it back to food
[Laughter]
[Music]